all our rice is growing in popularity as
a trendy substitute for carbohydrates
dense cauliflower is popping up in many
stores from organic markets to the
freezer aisle but the rice industry is
upset over the products name John
Blackstone digs into complaints that
cauliflower rice could be misleading and
confusing in the rich farmland of
California Salinas Valley and often
underrated vegetable is having its
moment in the Sun cauliflower is one of
the hottest vegetables we sell today
Jordan Greenberg is vice president of
green giant like you could use as a main
dish you could use it as a side dish it
can be barbecued baked stir-fry now
Green Giant is shredding cauliflower
into tiny bits creating a popular
substitute for rice with less than 15%
of the cars it's definitely making
vegetables more popular at the end of
the day consumers want to eat healthier
but cauliflower is now the center of a
controversy in a tale of rice and men
three giant describes its veggies as
rice and in this ad seem to challenge
the rice industry to get out of its way
do we need to call cauliflower rice rice
farmer Matthew sly gar has no intention
of moving over rice cauliflower
I mean why even call it rice cauliflower
could call it bits of cauliflower or
cauliflower crumbles and secondly winded
rice to become a verb for three
generations like ours family has been
growing rice in wet and muddy fields
north of Sacramento we are waist-deep in
rice here we are aren't we isn't it
beautiful convinced Americans should
know more about where their food comes
from these rice plants will be harvested
today slyger launched rice farming TV
we're about to fly the rice seed on this
field right about
it's like our worries rice cauliflower
is confusing consumers do you think
somebody calling cauliflower rice that's
gonna have an impact on your sales I
think it will and he's not alone
these days even rice farmers have
Washington lobbyists and they're asking
the Food and Drug Administration to
define rice so not everyone can use the
name cauliflower crumbles whatever you
want to call it let's put it in the
vegetable section in the produce section
and keep it out of the race aisle the
rice people are a little upset about you
using that name we feel we're being very
clear with what we're offering which is
rice vegetables the popularity is
spreading at erawan markets in Los
Angeles they make their own cauliflower
rice and consumer demand has made it a
bestseller instead of you know rice and
chicken they're doing cauliflower and
chicken you know what we have in common
with this little guy the desire to
survive but even a rice farmer admits he
can't live by rice alone but hey I'll be
open with you there's cauliflower in our
refrigerator it's just a head of
cauliflower and you eat the Hat I'll eat
that you know I'm not too excited about
it but I'll leave it what he won't do is
call it rice for this farmer that simply
goes against the grain for CBS this
morning John Blackstone Gridley
California